we all sleep and buy we all I mean all
animals from bugs to birds to people and
sleep looks the same on us from the
outside we lie down close our eyes stay
still but on the inside what our brains
are doing during sleep was thought to
unique to birds and mammals during sleep
for these animals the brain exhibits two
different patterns of activity slow-wave
sleep and rapid eye movement or REM
sleep but now it looks like reptiles
have a similar pattern of activity in
their sleep REM sleep alternating with a
slow wave type sleep throughout the
resting period researchers were able to
measure this type of sleep in lizards
for the first time using implanted
electrodes infrared cameras and
elaborate analysis one unique aspect of
lizard's sleep the lizard's sleep cycle
is only about 60 to 90 seconds long in
humans are complex sleep cycles last 60
to 90 minutes each does this mean that
lizards have short frequent dreams it's
still too early to tell if lizards or
even birds dream during their sleep but
what we do know is that our sleep
patterns are a lot older than once
thought at least 300 million years old
because lizards may be more similar to
our shared common ancestor studying
sleep in the reptile brain may be the
best way to learn more about how sleep
works for everyone